Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安（Marianne）。在深入今天的节目之前，我想先和大家分享一个目前正在进行、非常激动人心的消息。如果你曾想过如何创造源源不断的被动收入，而不是把时间无休止地出卖给金钱，那么你一定会喜欢由我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“持续收入冲刺挑战赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战赛旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入流。无论你是有志成为心理学家的准专业人士、心理健康从业者，还是来自完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Coming up in today's episode of the podcast, we are chatting to a brand new incoming trainee clinical psychologist who has recently learned she has gained a place on clinical
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会赢得由丽莎本人亲自送出的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战赛，你将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）一对一交流一小时的教练辅导机会。你想了解更多吗？你当然想。请访问我的 Linktree 页面 Dr. Marianne Trent，查看我的社交媒体账号，或者给我发个私信，我会告诉你所有详细信息。好了，让我们进入今天的节目。在今天的播客节目中，我们将与一位刚刚得知自己成功获得临床培训名额的新晋临床心理学实习生进行交流，
training. Listen to the whole episode to learn more about her, her unique take on the world and her journey to getting there. she also gives us her top tips towards the end of the session too so i do hope you find it useful if you're looking to become a psychologist then let this be your guide With this podcast at your side You'll be on your way to being qualified It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast With Dr. Marianne Trent
收听完整节目以了解更多关于她、她独特的见解以及她一路走来的历程。她在访谈接近尾声时还分享了她的核心建议，所以如果你正打算成为一名心理学家，我真心希望这期节目能对你有所帮助。有了这档播客在身旁，你将顺利通往获得专业资格的道路。这里是《有志心理学家播客》（The Aspiring Psychologist Podcast），我是玛丽安·特伦特博士。
Hi to you, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. One of the questions I get asked really pretty often is how can I get an assistant psychologist post? How long will it take me after I've graduated? When can I expect to get on clinical training? Is it too soon for me to get on clinical training? Why aren't I getting on clinical training? Is it my age? Is it my experience? Is it because I've had previous mental health experience? And today's episode is with somebody that has just in the last few weeks been notified that they've been successful at a doctorate in clinical psychology interview so come September they will be a trainee clinical psychologist and
大家好，欢迎收听《有志心理学家播客》。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，我是一名合格的临床心理学家。我经常被问到的问题之一是：我该如何获得助理心理学家的职位？毕业后需要多久才能拿到？我什么时候能开始临床培训？现在开始临床培训对我来说是不是太早了？为什么我总是申请不上临床培训？是因为我的年龄吗？是因为我的经验不够吗？是因为我有过心理健康方面的经历吗？今天的节目嘉宾在过去的几周里刚刚接到通知，她在临床心理学博士面试中成功过关，因此从今年九月份开始，她将成为一名临床心理学实习生，
I'm joined today by Nikita and Nikita is so wonderful to listen to and speak with. If you've read the Aspiring Psychologist Collective, you might well recognise her useful and I will look forward to catching up with you on the other side. If you do find this episode helpful please do like and subscribe to the podcast and leave me a comment if you're watching on YouTube. I'll catch you soon. Hi, welcome along to our guest for today. I am joined by Nikita. Nikita, thank you so much for coming to say hi to us. Well, thank you for inviting me. And a massive congratulations because a little birdie, in fact you on Twitter, told me that you have been accepted onto a doctoral training course to start in September, haven't you?
今天和我一起做客的是尼基塔（Nikita）。尼基塔非常健谈，和她交流是一种享受。如果你读过《有志心理学家文集》（The Aspiring Psychologist Collective），你很可能会认出她。非常感谢你能来和我们打招呼。谢谢你的邀请。首先要向你致以热烈的祝贺，因为有小道消息——其实是你自己在推特上透露的——说你已经被博士培训项目录取了，将在九月份入学，对吗？
I have. Not sure it's sunk in yet but yeah come autumn yeah. Well done how have you been celebrating or has it just been with a big long nap? Pretty much I've had lots of downtime I think it's quite a stressful experience having interviews so lots of lots of naps lots of downtime um and a few trips away at the weekend we stayed in a lodge just after interviews so that was a nice way to celebrate and unwind so nice sounds amazing really nice yeah just I guess really nourish yourself and do lots of nice things enjoy having no assignments between now and September is what I would say yeah absolutely it's the calm before the storm isn't it it is but that said I loved it
是的。我还不太确定这个好消息是不是真的沉淀下来了，不过是的，秋天就要开始了。太棒了！你是怎么庆祝的？还是说只是痛痛快快睡了个长觉？差不多就是这样，我有很多空闲时间。我觉得面试是一段压力很大的经历，所以有很多很多的午睡、很多休息时间，周末还出去旅行了几次。我们在面试结束后住进了一间度假小屋，那是庆祝和放松的好方法。听起来太棒了，真的很好。是的，我想就是好好犒劳自己，做很多开心的事。我想说的是，好好享受九月份之前没有作业的日子吧。是的，绝对是的。这是暴风雨前的平静，对吧？确实是这样，但话虽如此，我还是很喜欢这段经历，
you know um and I knew it would be tricky and I knew there'd be assignments and I knew there'd be juggling the work-life balance but I did really enjoy it and there were bits that were less enjoyable of course there were but I hope you find that it really helps you thrive as well. I'm really excited I'm sure it will even just thinking about the different placements and getting to work where I've never worked before um yeah that's exciting hard work but exciting yeah and when it comes to if you're on a course where you get to choose your specialist placements that's so cool because you're like well I'd love to do that and you go can I do that and they go yes and you're like amazing I've just created a job for myself and you know I'm the only applicant and they said yes
你知道的，我知道这会很棘手，我也知道会有作业，我也知道需要兼顾工作与生活，但我真的很享受其中。当然，也有一些部分没那么让人愉快，但我希望你发现这也能真正帮助你茁壮成长。我真的很兴奋，我相信一定会这样的，哪怕只是想到不同的实习经历，能够去我从未工作过的地方，是的，这让人兴奋，虽然辛苦但很让人兴奋。是的，当你可以选择自己的专科实习时，那就太酷了，因为你会想：“哦，我很想做那个。”然后你去问：“我能做那个吗？”他们回答：“可以。”然后你会觉得：“太棒了，我刚刚为自己创造了一份工作，而且我是唯一的申请者，他们还答应了。”
that has not happened at any point of our career so far yeah especially with the University of East Anglia and they have an international training opportunity for the third year so you can choose to go to Australia or Malaysia and that's exciting as well not knowing where my interest might take me and not knowing what that third year might look like I think everything's so interesting at this point there's no telling. And that's so nice because it really does free you up to make the decisions that are right for you and even among your cohort it might be that going abroad is right for some of you but going abroad is not going to be right for you and even among your cohort it might be that going abroad is right for some of you but going abroad is not going to be right for everybody because we've all got different
在我们的职业生涯中，之前从没有任何时刻发生过这种情况。特别是东英吉利大学（University of East Anglia），他们为第三年学员提供了国际培训机会，你可以选择去澳大利亚或马来西亚。这也是令人兴奋的一部分，不知道自己的兴趣会把自己带向何方，也不知道第三年会是什么样子。我觉得现在所有的事情都那么有趣，一切皆有可能。这太棒了，因为它真的能解放你，让你做出最适合自己的决定。甚至在你们同届学员中，出国对某些人来说是合适的，但对另一些人来说可能就不合适，因为我们每个人都有不同的
circumstances now it's useful to think a little bit about your circumstances because we were talking just before we began and I know a little bit about your story anyway because you've been a regular on our compassionate Q&As it It's always lovely to see you pop up. You're a YouTube watcher, aren't you? You like to watch via YouTube. But also you contributed to the Aspiring Psychologist Collective book that was published in October 2022. And so I feel like I know a little bit about you.
情况。现在，花点时间思考一下你自己的情况会很有用，因为在我们开始录制之前我们聊过，而且无论如何我对你的故事也略知一二，因为你是我们富有同情心的问答环节的常客。看到你露面总是很开心。你是YouTube的观众，对吧？你喜欢通过YouTube观看节目。而且你还为2022年10月出版的《有志心理学家文集》一书撰写了内容。所以我觉得我对你多少有些了解。
I almost wore my cashmere jumper to our chat today, but it's quite warm in our house today so I didn't um but could you tell us a little bit about about you um and about your journey um if that's all right yeah absolutely um it was a bit unconventional um for me I kind of wanted to figure out where I wanted to work in in mental health wise um before I decided to go to uni um so for me that looked like getting a foot in the door of the NHS first um and so my first job I was an apprentice and I think at that time it was band one minus 25 percent um which doesn't exist anymore so times have changed um and I was a therapeutic care support worker and that was on like a general hospital ward and so if patients came in um
我今天本来差点穿开司米羊毛衫来聊天，但今天家里挺暖和的，所以没穿。不过，如果可以的话，能跟我们简单聊聊你自己以及你的心路历程吗？当然可以。我的经历有点不太常规。在决定去上大学之前，我其实是想先弄清楚自己究竟想在心理健康领域的哪个具体方向工作。所以对当时的我和我而言，这意味着首先要一只脚迈进NHS（英国国家医疗服务体系）的大门。我的第一份工作是学徒，当时那个职位好像是第一级薪资减去25%，现在这个岗位已经不存在了，所以时代变了。我当时是一名治疗护理支持工作者，在综合医院的病房工作。如果病人住进来，
and they had dementia or mental health challenges or a brain injury um it was more to do with like safety and making sure that they had someone sat with them, but also providing like a meaningful interaction and not just being an extra body in the room. But that was, yeah, that was amazing. And I knew I wanted to work more in the mental health side of things. So from there, I think I was a trainee health care assistant in a psychiatric intensive care unit and worked across adult mental health wards at the same time and a few shifts in CAMHS and I knew there that I definitely did want to work in mental health but I couldn't figure out where I fit. I applied for nursing I think it was three times in total and got on each time but it just didn't feel completely like me and I didn't want to go and jump into a degree and then find out halfway through that it wasn't right so it came to the
患有痴呆症、心理健康问题或脑损伤，我的工作更多与安全有关，要确保有人陪在他们身边，同时还要提供有意义的互动，而不仅仅是病房里多了一个凑数的人。但那段经历真的是太棒了。我意识到自己更想从事心理健康方面的工作。从那以后，我想我曾是精神科重症监护室的医疗保健助理实习生，同时在成人心理健康病房工作过，还在儿童和青少年心理健康服务（CAMHS）值过几次班。在那里我确信自己确实想从事心理健康工作，但我一直弄不清自己究竟适合哪个具体方向。我申请护士专业好像总共申请了三次，每次都被录取了，但就是觉得这不完全适合我，我不想盲目跳进一个学位，然后到了一半才发现并不适合自己。所以后来，
point where I was kind of thinking about either psychiatry or psychology because I thought if it wasn't for me medicine would offer like a lot of different options and I was watching Grey's Anatomy at the time and quite like the idea of surgery so eventually when I figured out that psychology was it and I'd shadowed we had a responsible clinician that was a psychologist and I think it wasn't meant to be shadowing there just needed to be an extra person in the room to make sure that everything was safe but she was doing a formulation and writing it on the whiteboard and it just blew my mind and I remember thinking oh gosh one day I just hope that I can make sense of things like that and help somebody
我开始考虑精神病学还是心理学，因为我想，如果不是为了我自己，医学会提供很多不同的选择。当时我正在看《实习医生格蕾》（Grey's Anatomy），挺喜欢外科手术的想法。直到后来我弄清楚心理学才是我的真爱，当时我跟岗了一位心理学家。其实那次跟岗并不是特意安排的，只是病房里需要多一个人来确保一切安全。当时她正在做一个个案构思（formulation），并把它写在白板上，那一幕彻底震撼了我的世界。我还记得当时心里想：“天哪，总有一天我希望能把事情理得这么清楚，并且能帮到其他人去理解到底发生了什么。”
else to understand what's going on and she really took her time to explain how she came to all of these hypotheses and things and I just remember thinking I want to do that but I wasn't quite ready to go to uni at that point I think I still had a bit of maturing to do and I'd had lived experience as well so I had an eating disorder when I was younger I grew up dancing which is a whole toxic body environment kind of situation going on um and so I'd kind of thought about mental health from then just from from going through that um and I did go to drama school when I was 18 but the psychologist kind of sensed that I wasn't really into it I was just kind of going along with what I'd planned from being six because I'd never had any other career thoughts.
她花了很多时间向我解释她是如何得出所有这些假设的，我只记得当时想：“我也想做这个。”但当时我还没准备好上大学，我觉得自己在心智上还需要再成熟一点，而且我也有过亲身经历。我小时候患过进食障碍，成长过程中跳舞，那是一个充满有毒体型环境氛围的世界。从那时起我就开始思考心理健康问题，仅仅是因为经历了那些。我十八岁时去读了戏剧学校，但那位心理学家似乎察觉到我其实并不喜欢它，我只是在顺着自己从六岁起就规划好的路线走，因为我从来没有过别的职业想法。
And she'd asked, it's what everyone expects you to do. But what is it that you would want to do? And I just drew a blank and looked at her ID badge and read highly specialist applied psychologist, which I realize now wasn't subtle but I think yeah I reflected on this in my doctorate application form as well and I think it was just wanting to hold that safe space and that yeah that curious space for somebody else where they can just feel safe and explore what's going on and feel like they can take steps towards feeling better um and so I used that lived experience and became a peer support worker and at the time there was I think we were the first seven in the trust um so it was really really new and through that I kind of learned to just go with the flow not suggest anything not say have you tried CPT or um it was really difficult at first because I am a bit of a doer but just
她曾问过：“这是每个人都期望你做的。但你自己真正想做的是什么？”我当时脑子一片空白，看着她的工牌，上面写着“资深应用心理学家”。我意识到这当时并不委婉。不过我想是的，我在博士申请表中也反思了这一点。我想，这其实只是想为他人创造一个安全、充满好奇的空间，让他们能够感到安全、探索正在发生的事情，并觉得自己能够朝着感觉好转的方向迈出步伐。因此，我利用了那段亲身经历，成为了一名同伴支持工作者。当时我们好像是信托基金里的前七名成员，所以这是一个非常非常新的岗位。通过那段经历，我学会了顺其自然，不去建议任何事情，不说“你尝试过CBT（认知行为疗法）吗”之类的话。刚开始真的很困难，因为我是一个有点喜欢付诸行动的人，但只需
sitting back and listening and creating that therapeutic relationship without recommending things or um analyzing someone's thoughts or what they're saying um and so yeah it was at that point where I was like I have to go and do psychology I couldn't quite get the hang of walking alongside somebody that much I kind of wanted to take the next step and be like let's figure this out and let's yeah work together um and I had a word with with the psychologist that was in our team and just said what do you think um and quizzed her a little bit about psychology and went off to university and I think that's when I thought right well if I'm going to do this I just have to do three years at university I can apply to Oxford in my third year because they accept undergraduate applications and I'll be a clinical psychologist in six years and I didn't know how difficult it was um but I'm glad that
往后靠，静静倾听，建立起治疗关系，而不去推荐任何东西，也不去分析别人的想法或言论。所以在那个时候，我心想：“我必须去学心理学。”我实在无法适应那种仅仅陪伴在别人身边那么久的模式，我更想迈出下一步，去想“让我们把这个弄清楚，让我们一起努力吧”。我和我们团队里的那位心理学家聊了聊，说：“你觉得怎么样？”向她打听了一些关于心理学的事情，然后就去上大学了。我想那时我是这么想的：“好吧，既然我要做这件事，我就得在大学读三年，我可以在第三年申请牛津大学，因为他们接受本科生申请，这样我六年内就能成为一名临床心理学家了。”我当时并不知道这有多难，但我很高兴
I slowed down a little bit even though it seems like not a lot um but yeah I think I squeezed everything I could into that time did lots of research assistant stuff while I was at university and continued working I think until Covid hit I think I actually finished two weeks before our first lockdown which was a bit gutting because I didn't see that coming and I felt like I'd just left everyone while Covid was happening but yeah I think the whole research involvement was more to keep a connection to uni when uni was closed. But it worked really well. I learned so much. And then it came to the end of my degree and I decided to apply for my first assistant psych role. And that's where I think I kind of got that little I got in touch with that rebellious streak.
我稍微放慢了脚步，尽管看起来并没有慢多少。但我认为，我在那段时间里榨干了自己能做的一切，在大学期间做了很多研究助理的工作，并且继续工作，直到新冠疫情爆发。我想我实际上是在我们第一次封锁前两周完成的，这让人有点沮丧，因为我没有预料到这一点，而且我觉得在疫情发生时我刚刚离开了所有人。不过，整个研究参与过程更多是为了在大学关闭时保持与学校的联系，但效果非常好，我学到了很多东西。后来到了学业快结束的时候，我决定申请我的第一个助理心理学家职位。也就是在那里，我觉得自己触碰到了那种叛逆的特质。
And so when people say it's impossible, you can't apply before you've graduated I think I could just try so I put my application in and I did I had my first job offer before I'd submitted my dissertation which I didn't think was possible but was was happy with that um and now I'm here on my second assistant psych post, having submitted the form and with a place this year. So it's been a bit of a different journey. I think usually people get their experience after their degree. But most of mine came before. But it was really a process of both creating a strong foundation in myself, I think, and figuring out where I wanted to go with this career amazing what a story what a story bravo to Nikita for sure um you have been busy but I think you know generally speaking people don't tend to get AP posts straight from graduation so straight from being 21 that's more unusual but I think if you've if you've had really relevant experience and carved out super experience including research
所以当人们说“这不可能，你毕业前不能申请”时，我想我至少可以尝试一下。于是我递交了申请，而且在提交学位论文之前就收到了第一份工作录用通知，这在我看来是不可能的，但我对这个结果非常满意。现在我提交了申请表并在今年拿到了名额，目前正在做第二份助理心理学家工作。所以这是一段略有不同的旅程。我想通常人们是在毕业后才积累经验，但我的大部分经验都在之前。不过这确实是一个过程，既在内心为自己打下了坚实的基础，也摸索出了我想在这条职业生涯中走到哪里。太惊艳了，多么棒的故事！向尼基塔致以绝对的敬意。你一直都很忙，但我认为，总的来说，人们往往不会一毕业就直接拿到助理心理学家职位，也就是说在21岁刚毕业时就拿到并不常见。但如果你拥有非常相关的经验，并且在本科期间积累了超级棒的经验包括研究，
during your undergraduate then absolutely that's going to strengthen your skill set and make it so much more likely that you might well be shortlisted and successful. So when I was reading your account for the Aspiring Psychologist Collective, I think you're about to start your first AP post but what you've just said is you've done that and you're on to the next, like it's like you do everything at Nikita speed. Yeah I have been told that told that yeah I think I don't want to gloss over those those three months in my first AP post but I think it wasn't right for me and I think that's another thing to say as well is that they can feel like such gold dust jobs but not all AP roles are created equal and I think it takes a lot of guts to be
那么绝对会增强你的技能组合，让你更有可能进入候选名单并获得成功。所以当我阅读你在《有志心理学家文集》里的自述时，我想你当时正准备开始你的第一份助理心理学家工作，但你刚才所说的是，你已经完成了那份工作，并且已经进入下一阶段了，感觉你做什么都是“尼基塔速度”。是的，有人这么对我说过。我想我不想轻描淡写地带过我第一份助理心理学家那三个月的工作，但我认为那并不适合我。这也是需要说明的一点，这些职位感觉像是极其珍贵的金子，但并非所有的助理心理学家职位都是一样的。我认为，要想
able to leave something without knowing if you'll ever get another AP post but for me it was just it didn't sit right with me I felt yeah I felt like the power imbalance was too great for me to be able to speak up and I'm not great at not speaking up so I thought I think it's time for me to be able to speak up and I'm not great at not speaking up so I thought I think it's time for me to leave um but it was the best thing I've done actually and I'm glad I took that step um I'm working in in a team at the moment who are just incredible and I think I'll be really really sad to leave I could have done with an extra year maybe with them um but just the sort of things I've got to do um I think I started there in January in these few months is is amazing and I'm really enjoying it amazing so well done to you and I guess yeah your the message I'm getting loud and clear from you is be fearless be bold be brave you know
在不知道自己是否还能找到另一个助理心理学家职位的情况下勇敢离开，是需要很大勇气的。但对我而言，留在那里感觉不对劲。我觉得权力失衡太严重了，以至于我无法畅所欲言，而我又很不擅长闭口不言。所以我想，是时候离开了。但实际上这是我做过的最好的事，我很高兴自己迈出了这一步。我现在所在的团队简直不可思议，我想离开他们会让我感到非常非常难过。或许我应该和他们多待一年，但我在过去几个月里从一月份开始在那里做的事情真是太棒了，我真的很享受。太棒了！为你感到骄傲。我想从你身上得到的最响亮、最明确的信号就是：无所畏惧，大胆前行，勇敢面对。
do the thing that I think there's some similarities between you and I. Do the thing that comes up as an idea that maybe you could. Don't ask anyone permission. Just like, yeah, I wonder if I can. I'm going to try. I'm going to try. And because the answer might well be yes. That's it. The answer would definitely be a no if you don't submit that application. The thing is, I won't sit here and pretend I've always been optimistic um it was about two weeks before the deadline that I submitted my my application and I was telling the other AP that I was working with at the time
做那件我认为你我之间有相似之处的事。去付诸行动，哪怕只是一个可能可以实现的灵感。不要请求任何人的许可。就好像，是的，我想知道我能不能做到。我要试试。我会去试。因为答案很可能是“肯定的”。就是这样。如果你不提交那份申请，答案绝对是“否定”的。关键是，我不会坐在这里假装我一直都很乐观，嗯，大约在我提交申请截止日期前两周，我和当时一起工作的另一位助理心理学家（AP）谈过
that if you take the hype around it away and it's just the form you're perfectly capable of filling it out it's just that it's such a huge deal and then going home and not starting my form because I was panicking um and so yeah sometimes I could do with taking my own advice but when it comes down to it I think I do throw it out to the universe and see what comes back and I think that kind of helped my form as well because I must have had a few drafts and the first couple felt a bit stale I felt like I'd read the job description and and wrote what I thought courses would want to hear and you can't do that because there's not enough words anyway to get that all in there and so it forced me to kind of take a step back and be like right what matters to me what's important what do I want to say um and then I thought it's
如果你抛开围绕它的种种炒作，它其实只是一份表格，你完全有能力填好它。只不过这件事意义重大，然后回家后因为恐慌而没有开始填表，嗯，所以，有时候我也需要听取自己的建议，但说到头来，我想我还是会把一切交托给宇宙，看看会得到什么回应。我想这也对我的填表过程有所帮助，因为我肯定写过好几稿，前两稿感觉有点老套，我觉得自己只是读了职位描述，然后写下了我认为课程负责人想听到的话。你不能这样做，因为无论如何字数都不够把这些都塞进去，所以这迫使我退后一步，心想：好吧，什么对我有意义？什么才是重要的？我想表达什么？嗯，然后我想，这是
a risk because it didn't look like what I would expect a form to look like but it did look like me on paper and I thought if courses don't want it then I'd just try again next year and write a different application but I think that worked for me as well with it being um a sort of I wasn't going to be absolutely devastated and heartbroken if it was a no from from all four this year and I think that made it more um I was more able to take the risk because of that. I always say that a form should be entirely unique for you the way you've lived your life the way you see the world the things you've experienced the adversity you've struggled with it's got to be a bit of you because otherwise it's not authentic it's not genuine and it feels like you're trying on someone else's bear suit you know it doesn't fit and you know it's not convincing and it feels like you're trying on someone else's bear suit you know it doesn't
一场冒险，因为它看起来不像我预期中表格该有的样子，但它在纸面上看起来确实很像我。我想，如果课程不想要它，那我明年再试一次，写一份不同的申请。但我认为这对我挺管用的，因为我当时的心态是，如果今年所有四个申请都被拒绝，我也不会彻底崩溃和心碎。我认为正因如此，我更能承担这个风险。我总是说，表格应该完全为你量身定制——根据你的生活方式、你看待世界的方式、你经历过的事情、你奋斗过的逆境。它必须带有一点你的个人特色，否则它就不真实，不真诚，感觉就像你在穿别人的熊皮玩偶服，你知道，它根本不合身，而且你知道这毫无说服力，感觉就像你在穿别人的熊皮玩偶服，你知道，这根本不
fit and you know it's not convincing and your arms don't quite go to the end you know because it's not custom made for you and it should be I will share as well in my first draft um if there's a little section that asks uh what are your interests aside from psychology and being a really big kind of obsessed with psychology person I don't have many things outside of psychology and so I was like right what are they asking here they want to know that you can switch off at the end of the day I'll say I like walking so I wrote that I like walking I absolutely don't I'm terrible at walking I won't walk unless it's a coffee shop at the end and so I asked my mum to read it and I
合身，而且你知道这毫无说服力，你的胳膊根本伸不到头，你知道的，因为这不是为你定制的。它本来就应该是这样的。我还要分享一点，在我的第一稿中，嗯，有一个小节问：除了心理学，你还有什么兴趣爱好？由于我是一个对心理学非常痴迷的人，我除了心理学之外几乎没有什么别的爱好。所以我当时就想：好吧，他们在这里到底想问什么？他们是想知道你在一天结束时能够切换状态。我就说我喜欢散步。于是我写道我喜欢散步。我其实一点也不喜欢，我最讨厌散步了，除非终点是一家咖啡馆，否则我是绝不会走路的。所以我让我妈妈读了这一段，我
said tell me what you think of this first draft and she was like you're going to go into these interviews if they offer you one they're going to ask you what your favorite walking trail is and then you'll be stumped won't you and I thought yeah maybe not so I switched it out for Billie Eilish and she was in my doctorate application instead so much more authentic I love it out for Billie Eilish and she was in my doctorate application instead. So much more authentic. I love it. But you've hit on quite an important nail there. And that's when I met my husband. He was like, this is 2009. So I met him during the very early stages. I think it was the second week of year two of my training um and he was like isn't the first conversation we had because I don't think I'd have pursued it but he said you don't why don't you do more like what you're like you haven't got any interest like
说：你觉得这第一稿怎么样？她说：如果他们给你面试机会，你走进面试室，他们会问你最喜欢哪条徒步路线，到时候你就要被问住，对吧？我想：嗯，也许不行。所以我把它换成了比利·艾利什（Billie Eilish），她反而出现在了我的博士申请里，真实多了，我太喜欢了。把它换成了比利·艾利什，她反而出现在了我的博士申请里。真实多了，我太喜欢了。但你确实切中了要害。那就是我遇到我丈夫的时候。当时是2009年。所以我是在我培训第二年刚开始的很早阶段认识他的，我想当时是第二周，他说……这不是我们的第一次对话，因为我觉得我当时不会继续追问下去，但他说：你为什么不……为什么不多做点像你平时的样子？你没有任何爱好，就像
you just I don't know you like you talk about pilates you sometimes do that and you like chatting to your friends on the phone but like you don't you don't do anything you read books that's that's that's like it and I was like I love my job I'm so fulfilled by my job and actually carving out this career has absolutely been my passion and my hobby and my pastime and a real pleasure and I don't think that's something that everybody gets so yes courses want to know that you're not just like some big psychology geek but it wasn't that for me it was that I think I was so fulfilled by my work life that I could kind of free myself up to just be in the evenings and the weekends I didn't need to go and be rock climbing and you know doing all these outlandish
你只是……我不知道，你喜欢普拉提，有时候会练练，你喜欢和朋友打电话聊天，但是，除此之外你什么都不做。你只会读书，那就这样了。而我当时想：我热爱我的工作，我的工作让我感到无比充实。事实上，开辟这条职业道路绝对是我的激情所在、业余爱好、消遣方式以及真正的乐趣所在。我觉得并不是每个人都能得到这种体验。所以，是的，课程负责人想知道你不仅仅是个狂热的心理学书呆子，但对我和大多数人来说并非如此。是因为我觉得我的工作生活如此充实，以至于我可以腾出时间，在夜晚和周末享受纯粹的自我。我不需要去攀岩，也不需要（你知道的）去做那些稀奇古怪的
pursuits because I was already so fulfilled and probably mentally exhausted by my day job yeah that's it isn't it and like I used to go through like I did uni through lockdown and so you could there was not much to do you couldn't go outside for some bits of that and I'd wake up log onto my laptop and then shut it down and go to sleep and for some people that sounds like torture but it was exactly what I wanted to be doing for like 15 hours of my day um and I still do watch some brain anatomy videos sometimes before I go to sleep as a hobby and so yeah that one was a struggle for me answering that question because a lot of my life is about either reading about psychology working as an assistant psychologist um but I wouldn't change it I absolutely do love
追求，因为我的精神已经得到了极大的充实，而且日常工作可能已经让我精疲力竭了。是的，就是这样，不是吗？就像我以前经历的那样，我在疫情封锁期间读完大学，所以当时没什么可做，其中有一段时间你甚至不能出门。我会醒来，登录笔记本电脑，然后关机去睡觉。对某些人来说，这听起来像是折磨，但这正是我一天中想要度过15小时的方式。嗯，我有时在睡觉前仍然会看一些大脑解剖视频作为爱好。所以，是的，回答那个问题对我来说是个挣扎，因为我的生活很大一部分都围绕着阅读心理学、担任助理心理学家，但我绝不会改变这一点，我确实非常热爱
it and I know that you're not supposed to say that in interviews but it's a reason why I wanted to do it it's authentic and also I think that level of determination and commitment and enthusiasm and hours of learning have meant that I think realistically Nikita you've shaved a couple of years off the journey to becoming a an incoming trainee in psych and I think that's your I don't know your confidence you know some of the probably adversities that you went through earlier on in your years have caused you to reflect caused you to adapt and change and just maybe be in a slightly different position than other people at your stage of your career maybe even your age are at right now and so we're not all born equal we don't all have the
它，我知道你在面试中不应该这么说，但这就是我想做这件事的原因，这很真实。而且我也认为，那种决心、承诺、热情和无数的学习小时意味着，说实话，尼基塔，你为自己成为一名心理学准培训师的旅程缩短了好几年的时间。我认为这是你的……我不知道，你的自信，你知道的，早年经历的一些逆境促使你反思、适应和改变，或许让你处于一个比你现阶段职业生涯中的其他人、甚至比你现在这个年龄的人略微不同的位置。所以我们并非生而平等，我们并没有经历
same struggles but it's what we make of what we've been through and how we talk about it and reflect upon it and also something that people tell me quite often is is how connected you are to it when you talk about it so we can't be too disconnected we can't be too intellectualized about it you've got to somehow be able to talk about this stuff like it matters and like you are connected to it still but not so connected that you're crying you know it's that fine balance isn't it yeah that's been something that I've really had an experience with since starting this new role um my supervisor's great and I think she gets me and gets how I work um and she said to me you've read a lot and now it's just about how you're bringing that into what you're doing. And I kind of do get that is that I know the stuff, but it seems different when I've got a person sat in front of me and I've been working through that on how I'm talking about things. Because some people really like talking about, I think a lot of people, I work in a persistent physical symptom service.
完全相同的挣扎，但关键在于我们如何利用自己的经历，如何谈论它并从中反思。另外，人们经常对我说的一点是，当你谈论它时，你是多么与它保持连接。所以我们不能过于抽离，不能对它过度理智化。你必须以某种方式谈论这些事情，就好像它真的很重要，就好像你依然与它有着深深的连接，但又不能深情到当场落哭。就是这种微妙的平衡，对吧？是的，自从担任这个新角色以来，我对此确实深有体会。我的督导非常棒，我觉得她很懂我，也懂我的工作方式。她对我说：你读了很多书，现在关键在于你如何将这些知识融入到你正在做的事情中。我其实挺理解这点的，就是说我知道这些内容，但当我面对一个真实的客户时，情况就变得不一样了，我一直在摸索如何表达这些事情。因为有些人真的很喜欢讨论——我觉得很多人都这样，我在一个持续性躯体症状服务部门工作
And so when the psychiatrist talks to people about polyvagal theory, I work in the persistent physical symptom service and so so when the psychiatrist talks to people about polyvagal theory I work in the persistent physical symptom service and that can help them to connect with mind and body so it's sort of looking at examples like that and thinking how am I using theory because you can't just preach at someone and with a manualized intervention which I think the ACP recommends that assistant psychs deliver um which is most of my work it's hard to kind of stray from the manual just enough that you still cover the full content but that you're there and being human and I think it's actually helped me having a manual in front of me because I'm not thinking
当精神科医生跟人们谈论多迷走神经理论时，我在持续性躯体症状服务部门工作，所以当精神科医生跟人们谈论多迷走神经理论时，我在持续性躯体症状服务部门工作，这可以帮助他们连接身心。因此，我们需要观察这样的例子，思考我该如何运用理论，因为你不能只是对别人高谈阔论。在手册化的干预治疗中（ACP建议助理心理学家开展这种治疗，这也是我大部分的工作内容），很难在稍微偏离手册的同时，既能涵盖全部内容，又能保持真实的人性。我认为手头有一本手册其实对我很有帮助，因为我不用去思考
about what comes next or how am I going to explain this um because it's there sometimes you need to re-explain but that's fine um yeah so I think it has I I worried being at uni that going back into an assistant psych job I'd have forgotten how to people that just sit there in front of someone and be like what do I do now um but yeah I think that's something you can always fall back on isn't it is your ability to relate to someone absolutely and I think that the pandemic sort of helped us be a bit more human and a bit more people in with people um because it seemed to level us in a way that nothing else had so um before the pandemic
下一步该做什么，或者我该如何解释这些，因为内容就在那里。有时你需要重新解释，但这没关系。所以，是的，我觉得确实如此。我在大学时曾担心，重新回到助理心理学的工作岗位上，我会忘记如何与人相处，忘记如何坐在某人面前却不知所措。但我觉得，总有一点是你可以倚仗的，那就是你与他人建立联系的能力，绝对是这样。而且我认为大流行某种程度上帮助我们变得更有人情味，更懂得如何与人相处，因为这在某种程度上拉近了我们的距离，这是以往任何事情都无法比拟的。所以，在疫情之前
um I would experience like corridor conversations where someone might say oh hello but really that was it about me you know that's where it stopped whereas often I think since the pandemic there's been much more of well how are you how is that and it's felt appropriate and for me it's about appropriate to to share that and make it much more two-way than it ever has been in any of my roles before yeah definitely and I think even in the way that we work in a team um our team has well-being Wednesdays where we get together for half an hour every Wednesday afternoon. And I think a lot of that came out of Covid and not having that connection. We all kind of realised how important it was. I love that. I just had an impulsive thought. Is there cake at wellbeing Wednesday?
嗯，我经常会经历走廊上的偶遇，别人可能会说“哦，你好”，但也就仅此而已了，你知道的，交流到这就结束了。而相反，我觉得自疫情以来，有了更多的交流，比如“你好吗？最近怎么样？”这感觉很合适。对我来说，分享这些并使之比以往任何时候都更加双向，是顺理成章的。是的，绝对是这样。而且我认为，甚至在我们团队的工作方式中也是如此，我们团队有“福祉星期三”（well-being Wednesdays），每个星期三下午我们都会聚在一起半小时。我想这很大程度上源于新冠疫情以及缺乏那种连接的时期，我们都意识到这种连接有多么重要。我太喜欢这个了。我刚才突然有个冲动的问题：“福祉星期三”有蛋糕吗？
Absolutely. Yeah. But then someone said apparently a slice of cake is like promoting nicotine in the workplace. So we should be having healthy wellbeing Wednesdays, but no, they need cake. Yeah, I definitely heard about this on the radio a few months ago where they were talking about actually, it's kind of like peer pressure. It's very tricky to not eat something off the share table. And that is something that unless you've worked in a, probably an NHS service or any kind of office environment, that you don't really understand. Because my husband's like, if you don't want it, you don't eat it.
绝对有。是的。但随后有人说，一块蛋糕显然就像是在工作场所宣传尼古丁。所以我们应该举办健康的“福祉星期三”，但是，不，他们需要蛋糕。是的，几个月前我确实在收音机里听过这个话题，他们谈到其实这有点像同辈压力。要在分享桌上忍住不吃东西是非常棘手的。除非你在国家医疗服务体系（NHS）或某种办公室环境工作过，否则你很难真正理解这一点。因为我丈夫会说：“如果你不想吃，你就不吃呗。”
I'm like, well, it doesn't work like that. You know, because once you see those cookies, you start digesting those cookies. And then you might have a stressful encounter. You come upstairs and you see a cookie. That cookie is mine. Whereas it isn't necessarily calories that you factored in to your you know your week's worth of food and so it's additional calories um and even even fruit on the share table it's the same deal you know it's stuff
我说：“事情才不是这样的呢。”你知道的，因为一旦你看到那些曲奇饼干，你就会开始在脑海中消化它们。接着你可能会遇到一件压力很大的事，你走上楼梯，看到了曲奇饼干，就会觉得“那块饼干是我的”。然而，这并不一定是你在每周的食物热量预算中考虑进去的，所以这是额外的热量。甚至分享桌上的水果也是一样的道理，你知道的，这些都是你
that you wouldn't necessarily have eaten so i think it's definitely an important conversation but what i know about being a psychologist is that we do tend to eat cakes as does everybody I think and we have staff with well-being walks to combat that so we have it's moderation isn't it it's balance yeah yeah and you know sometimes it's the biscuits that get you through the meetings. It is. Sometimes I just used to show up for the biscuits, you know. I think it's the most well-attended meeting in our week. There you go. I love a well-being Wednesday.
平时不一定会吃的东西。所以我觉得这绝对是一个重要的讨论话题。不过我对心理学家的了解是，我们往往和大家一样都喜欢吃蛋糕。为了抵消这一点，我们有员工健康步道（well-being walks）。所以这就是适度，对吧？这就是平衡。是的，是的，有时候正是饼干帮你熬过了一场又一场会议。确实如此。有时候我以前去开会就是为了饼干，你知道的。我想这是我们一周中出席率最高的会议。你看，我就喜欢“福祉星期三”。
Amazing. Can you offer us any top tips for reducing burnout on the way to this coveted lofty title that you are holding in the air? Yeah, this is this has been a journey for me, I want to say. I found out during university that I'm dyscalculic. And so having this sort of notion that I was going to need to work harder didn't, it served me because I ended up with the grade that I wanted. But I've worked a lot more than I would have done had I not been equipped with this new information. And I think someone told me there's a time for sowing the seeds and there's a time for sitting back and watching them grow and I think that's so important I think I sowed for a bit too long um and I did I would say I'd been out at the end of university I the thought
太棒了。在通往你现在这个备受追捧的崇高头衔的路上，你能不能给我们提供一些减少职业倦怠的顶级建议？是的，这一路走来对我来说是一段旅程，我想这么说。我在大学期间发现自己患有计算障碍（dyscalculic）。因此，认为自己需要加倍努力的这种想法，确实帮了我，因为我最终取得了想要的成绩。但如果没有掌握这个新信息，我付出的努力会比实际要多得多。有人曾对我说过：播种有播种的时候，坐看它们生长也有坐看它们生长的时候。我觉得这太重要了。我想我播种的时间稍微长了一点，嗯，而且我确实……可以说是到了大学结束的时候，一想到
of doing a master's made me want to be a little bit sick and I just thought I really need a break and I wasn't very bound reading what I was doing and like I say through Covid you'd wake up you'd put your laptop on and you'd turn it off when you went to bed and sometimes that was what I wanted to do but when it's a research module and you're trying to get your head around stats and you're doing a 20-hour exam because it was supposed to be two hours but you've got two days to complete it and I did have screen time that was 20 hours and I don't think I was very sensible with it um I think it's about recognizing that you've you've hit that place ideally before you've hit that place but when you have recognizing that it happened and and not letting it happen again so now um as an ap i don't work
要读硕士学位就让我感到有点恶心，我只是觉得我真的需要休息一下。而且我在做事时并没有设定好边界。就像我说的，在疫情期间，你会醒来，打开笔记本电脑，然后在上床睡觉时把它关掉。有时这正是我想要做的，但当这是一个研究模块，而你试图理解统计数据时，你得应付一个20小时的考试（因为它本应是两个小时，但你却有两天时间完成），我当时的屏幕使用时间确实达到了20个小时，我觉得自己在这方面实在不太理智。我认为关键在于认识到自己已经达到了那个极限——理想情况下是在达到那个极限之前——但当确实达到了时，要承认它的发生，并且不要让它再次发生。所以现在，作为一名助理心理学家，我不再
over my hours that often partly because i drive an hour to to my workplace and if i leave it 10 minutes later it'll mean i'm half an hour later home um so i'd yeah, don't be a yes person. Just put those boundaries in place. Take your lunch breaks, uh, recognize what you need. I know you mentioned sometimes you're so exhausted during the day that you just want to chill out on the night. Um, I like that. I like downtime. Um, I think relying on the people around you as well, and also supporting them through whatever they're going through and that's important but I'd say you can't go far wrong if you're making sure that you have have a balance of work and things that give you energy and make you happy and just keeping track of what you need amazing thank you what brilliant advice and one of the things I really like about you Nikita and
经常加班。部分原因是我开车去工作地点需要一个小时，如果我晚走10分钟，回家就会晚半个小时。所以，是的，不要做一个有求必应的人。设定好边界。按时吃午休，嗯，认清自己的需求。我知道你提到有时白天精疲力竭，晚上只想放松一下。嗯，我喜欢这样。我喜欢休息时间。嗯，我觉得还要依靠身边的其他人，并在他们经历艰难时刻时支持他们，这也很重要。但我要说的是，只要确保在工作与那些能为你提供能量、让你快乐的事情之间保持平衡，并且随时关注自己的需求，你就不会出太大差错。太棒了，谢谢你，多么棒的建议啊。我真的很喜欢你的一点，尼基塔，而且
I was struck by this and I was reading your account and I'm struck by this again today is that you remind me of the writing style of the chap that wrote Angela's Ashes which I will say is one of my all-time favorite books because there's like a big narrative about you know this this thing that's small but beautiful and then there's like a tiny little snippet oh yeah and this this and this happened and with his example it was like oh yeah my brother died you know and like he literally just said that and then you don't say anything more about it and in your narrative in the um the aspiring psychologist collective you're like oh i won some award from the british society and you've done it a few times in your story and then you've done it today as oh yeah and I'm dyscalculic as well he's like oh right okay so that too like these are big things um
当我阅读你的自述时我深有感触，今天再次听到你分享时我依然深受触动：你让我想起了创作《安吉拉的灰烬》（Angela's Ashes）的那位作者的写作风格。我要说，那是我有生以来最喜欢的书之一。因为书里有一种宏大的叙事——你知道的，讲述着某种虽然渺小但却美好的事物——然后突然有一个极其微小的片段：“哦，对了，发生了这事、那事和那事。”在他书中的例子就像是：“哦，对了我哥哥死了，”你知道的，他就像那样轻描淡写地随口一提，然后就再也没多说什么。而在你的叙事中，在“有志心理学家集体”（the aspiring psychologist collective）里，你说：“哦，我赢得了英国学会的某个奖项。”在你的故事里，你这样轻描淡写了好几次，今天你也是这样：“哦，对了，我还患有计算障碍。”他就好像：“哦，好吧，原来如此。”诸如此类——这些可都是大事啊。
you know that have also been potentially you know really worth either shouting about or that have been adversities but you've triumphed over and above that so like even to consider going on to psychiatry if you're dyscalculic like amazing yeah I think it's as well it's a little bit of that internalized ableism isn't it that we all kind of have to some degree and especially going into psychology I think I'm very aware of what I'm saying and what parts of my story I will share. And I think that comes from peer support as well, of just knowing what feels comfortable and safe. So I know that I'm comfortable talking about my experience in CAMHS and having an eating disorder because it's not something that's an issue for me at the minute.
你知道的，有些经历可能真的很值得大声说出来，或者虽然经历过逆境，但你最终战胜了它们，所以，甚至考虑去从事精神病学，如果你有计算障碍还敢这样做，太厉害了。是的，我认为这也有一点内化的能力歧视，不是吗？我们多多少少都有点这种倾向，特别是进入心理学领域，我认为我非常清楚自己在说什么，以及会分享我故事的哪些部分。我想这也来自于同伴支持，就是知道什么让人感到舒适和安全。所以我知道我乐于谈论自己在CAMHS的经历以及曾患进食障碍，因为目前这对我都不是什么问题了。
And I think we all have really deep experiences as humans that we don't necessarily display to the world. But if you can tap into it um you can you do some great stuff and i think we're heading that way especially with the neurodiversity movement and the lived experience um underpinnings of what we're doing now there's a lot in research we always have experts by experience leading or steering the project and and so we are going in a good way and I think yeah we all have these layers don't we we do we have many layers and I'm I'm excited that there's going to be the field of clinical psychology with you in it and I'm excited to see how those layers
并且我认为作为人类，我们都有很深层的经历，不一定都会向世界展露。但如果你能挖掘它，嗯，你就能做出很棒的事情。而且我认为我们正朝着这个方向前进，尤其是随着神经多样性运动以及我们现在所做事情的亲身经历基础，在研究中有很多地方我们总是让有亲身经历的专家来领导或指导项目，因此我们正朝着好的方向发展。并且我认为是的，我们都有这些层面的经历，对吧？的确，我们有很多层面。我很兴奋能看到临床心理学领域有你的加入，我也很期待看到这些层面
develop which narratives you know get thicker which ones get thinner which ones you run with which ones you might leave behind because that's the beauty of clinical placements as well is that you can you know you can leave behind the bits that don't work for you and keep the ones that do it's really wonderful so thank you so much um for taking time at the end of your busy day and after your commute and everything to speak with us and guide us through your story it's been incredible it's been an absolute pleasure I was nervous at the start and it's been great so thank you for being so welcoming and letting me come on here and speak I'm delighted I'm really thrilled that you said yes and it's yeah it's nice to put a face to the name because you always show up for my compassionate Q&As.
如何发展，哪些叙事你会认为变得更丰满，哪些变得更单薄，哪些你会继续坚持，哪些你可能会抛在脑后，因为这也是临床实习的美妙之处，你可以，你知道的，你可以抛开那些对你不适用的部分，保留那些对你有用的部分，这真的很棒。所以非常感谢你在忙碌了一天结束时，在通勤和各种事情之后，还能抽空与我们对话，引导我们了解你的故事，这太不可思议了。这绝对是一种荣幸，我一开始很紧张，但现在感觉太棒了，所以谢谢你这么热情地欢迎我，让我来这里发言。我很高兴，真的很高兴你答应了，而且，能把名字和真人对上号感觉真好，因为你总是出现在我的同情心问答直播中。
It's always lovely to see you. So thank you. And I'm pleased that you found whatever I've done useful. And thank you for giving back and helping so richly this audience of ours. And stay part of my world. Keep me updated with how it goes. I'm wishing you the very best for your training and everything that happens in your life during it because that is what happens during training you your life will continue and you
能见到你总是很高兴。所以谢谢你。我很高兴你觉得我做的一切都有用。谢谢你给予的回馈，并为我们的听众提供了如此丰富的帮助。继续做我世界的一部分吧。随时告诉我你的近况。我祝愿你学业顺利，并祝愿你在培训期间生活中发生的一切都顺心如意，因为这就是培训期间会发生的事情，你的生活将继续，而你
said yourself during the last year of your undergrad three people died like I'm really sorry to hear that but this you know life is what happens when you're trying to pursue a psychology career yeah yeah it's huge. And I think those are the little things that we don't realise how resilient we are until we go through. Not that we'd ever choose to go through them. But, yeah, thank you. And it has been hard work, but it shapes you. It does shape you, yeah. And it's okay to be sad about the things that are difficult, you know.
自己也说过，在本科最后一年有三个人去世了，天哪，听到这个消息我很难过，但你知道的，这就是当你试图追求心理学职业生涯时生活所发生的事情。是的，是的，这太重大了。我认为这些都是小事情，直到我们亲身经历过，才意识到自己有多么坚强。并不是说我们会选择去经历这些。但是，是的，谢谢你。这确实是一段艰辛的工作，但它塑造了你。它确实塑造了你，是的。对于那些艰难的事情感到难过也没关系，你知道的。
Absolutely. Yeah, absolutely. And it's okay to be sad about the things that are difficult, you know. Absolutely. I say that because I've got a broken arm and I'm really grumpy about it. I think I'm hoping I'm coming out the other side of that now. Good. I'm going to be sling-faced outside the house for at least the next sort of four-ish weeks. But in the house, I don't always wear it. But when I'm on Zoom Zoom I find if I don't do that I start trying to pick things up with my left hand and then I'm like um so yeah when I'm
绝对的。是的，绝对的。对于那些艰难的事情感到难过也没关系，你知道的。绝对的。我这么说是因为我手臂骨折了，对此我真的很烦躁。我想我希望我现在正走出那个阴影。很好。我至少在接下来的四周左右时间里，出门都得挂着吊带。但在家里，我不总是戴着它。不过当我在Zoom开会时，我发现如果不戴它，我就会开始试着用左手去拿东西，然后我就会想……所以，是的，当我在
when I'm on Zoom and stuff and streaming I try and remind myself that I'm a little incapacitated so I don't do it but yes thank you so much I will actually let you go despite having several false starts of saying this is the end this is the end but thank you it's been incredible and I feel like I could talk to you probably for weeks so thank you again Nikita thanks so much cheers hi it's Nikita I thought I'd pop back because I have a bit of an update since Marianne and I spoke to record the podcast. So as you all know I was offered a place at East Anglia and I was all set to move down there in the autumn. I was also on the reserve list for a place for Teesside University and now I've been offered a place and I've accepted it so I'll be studying
在Zoom上开会和直播等活动时，我尽量提醒自己我有点行动不便，这样我就不会那样做了。不过是的，非常感谢，我真的要放你走了，尽管我已经好几次假装要结束并说“这就是尾声、这就是尾声”。但谢谢你，这太不可思议了，我觉得我大概能跟你聊上好几周。所以再次感谢尼基塔，非常感谢，再见。嗨，我是尼基塔，我想我还是回来补充一下，因为自从我和玛丽安录完播客后，我有了一些最新进展。如大家所知，我获得了东英吉利大学的录取名额，我本来已经准备好在秋天搬到那里去了。我还处于蒂赛德大学录取名额的候补名单上，现在我得到了录取通知并接受了它，所以我将去
at Teesside University. I'm really excited, I get to stay at home. I get to continue working in the trust that I've always worked for. And I also think it's really cool that the university that I did my undergraduate degree at will also be the reason that I can call myself Dr. Shefferson in three years. So yeah, I'm over the moon and I just wanted to update you all thank you for listening to the podcast bye oh my god I really really enjoyed that and I hope you did too just as we were drawing to a close Nikita told me um that she loves this podcast and so being on it was really special to her which was lovely to hear. She also told me that her doctoral interview at UEA was in person and they did an amazing buffet and I was like
蒂赛德大学学习。我真的非常兴奋，我可以留在家里了。我可以继续在我一直工作的信托机构里工作。我也觉得非常酷的是，我攻读本科的大学，也将成为我在三年后能称呼自己为谢弗森博士的原因。所以，是的，我欣喜若狂，我只是想向大家更新这个消息，谢谢大家收听播客，再见。天哪，我真的非常非常喜欢那次访谈，希望你们也是。就在我们快要结束时，尼基塔告诉我，她非常喜欢这个播客，所以能参与其中对她来说非常特别，听到这个我很高兴。她还告诉我，她在东英吉利大学的博士面试是线下进行的，他们准备了超级棒的自助餐，而我当时就想，
you know me I love a buffet so yeah if when you're considering where to apply you also enjoy a great buffet then you might want to consider UEA. Another little snippet that we didn't get in the recorded time but we did get afterwards was that Nikita had applied obviously to four courses because that's the maximum number that you can apply to but you might only choose to apply for one that's okay too so she'd applied to four courses and she did actually get offered four interviews so it's not impossible you know dreams can come true if you buy a ticket if you apply if you you know if you put your toe in the water if you you know tell the universe this is what i want then the universe might well respond and say okay here's your chance off you go um but Nikki also said she decided to turn down one of the
你们了解我，我最爱自助餐了。所以，如果你们在考虑申请哪里时，也很喜欢丰盛的自助餐，那么你们可以考虑东英吉利大学。另一个小花絮是我们在录音时没有聊到、但录音结束后聊到的，那就是尼基塔显然申请了四个课程，因为那是你可以申请的最高数量，但你可能只选择申请一个，那也没关系，所以她申请了四个课程，并且确实收到了四个面试邀请。所以这并非不可能，如果你买了一张彩票、如果你去申请、如果你把脚伸进水里试探、如果你告诉宇宙这就是我想要的，那么宇宙很可能会回应并说“好的，给你个机会，去吧”。不过尼基塔还说，她决定放弃其中一个
interviews um because she knew that actually realistically it was going to be really quite far in terms of moving for her so she decided to let that one go with love and kindness and compassion um and so she decided to turn that down and give someone else the chance of being interviewed who was on the reserve list so um if you were interviewed in Essex you might well have Nikita to thank and I'm sure she would love it if you ended up getting a place you know because then she's changed lives which is just amazing I love being part of this psychology world so we would love to know what you think to this episode come along and tell us on socials I am Dr Marianne
面试，因为她知道现实中从搬迁的角度来看，那个地方实在太远了，所以她决定带着爱、善意和同情心放弃那个机会，并把面试的机会让给候补名单上的其他人。所以，如果你曾在埃塞克斯接受过面试，你很可能会感谢尼基塔，而且我相信如果你最终被录取了，她一定会非常高兴，因为那样她就改变了别人的生活，这真是太棒了。我喜欢成为这个心理学世界的一部分。所以我们很想知道你对这期节目的看法，来社交媒体上告诉我们吧。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，
Trent everywhere and you can also come along the aspiring psychologist community free facebook group if you haven't yet read the Aspiring Psychologist Collective, which does have Nikita's story in it, then you can grab a copy of that by checking out the link in the show notes. Thank you so much for being part of my world. Thank you again to my guest for today, Nikita, wishing her all the very best in her training. And yeah, I will catch up with you soon. The next episode of the podcast is available from 6am on Monday. Take care. So many tips and lessons to learn from.
到处都是。你也可以加入“有抱负的心理学家社区”免费脸书群组。如果你还没读过《有抱负的心理学家合集》，里面包含了尼基塔的故事，那么你可以通过查看节目简介中的链接来获取一本。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。再次感谢我今天的嘉宾尼基塔，祝她在培训中一切顺利。好的，我们很快再聊。播客的下一期节目将于周一早上6点发布。保重。有这么多的技巧和经验可以学习。
So many things that you can try. The Aspiring Psychologist Collective. The Aspiring Psychologist Collective. If you're looking to become a psychologist Then let this be your guide With this podcast, I feel sad You'll be on your way to being qualified It's the Aspiring Psychologist podcast With Dr. Marianne Trent my name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner I read the clinical
有这么多的事情你可以尝试。《有抱负的心理学家合集》。《有抱负的心理学家合集》。如果你想成为一名心理学家，那么就让它成为你的向导。有了这个播客，我觉得很欣慰。你将走上获得资质的道路。这就是《有抱负的心理学家》播客，我是玛丽安·特伦特博士。我叫雅娜，我是一名实习心理健康从业者。我读了《临床
psychologist collective book I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist it just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself so if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
心理学家合集》这本书，我发现里面关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历都非常有趣。达到这个目标竟然有这么多不同的途径，这让我惊叹不已，而且并没有什么成为心理学家的“完美方式”。这给了我信心，让我觉得“不，我并没有做错”，并减轻了我的压力。所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你翻开这本书，你就不会把它放下了。这期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。